[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده وما
يجري في داخل اسرائيل والاعلام الاسرائيلي
وصديقنا الدكتور احمد فؤاد انور مساء
الخير معال الدكتور اهلا سيد بيس صديق
العزيز انا عندي سؤال ملح جدا قبل ما نبدا
الحلقه افضل لفت نظري واظن لفت نظر كثير
من الناس ما حدث بعد يوم 15 ديسمبر
الجاري الاسرائيليين او الجيش الاسرائيلي
تورت في قتل ثلاثه من رهائن او المحتجزين
في غزه صحيح هل تاذن لي اذكر الناس بس
الاول بالحارث يوم 15 الجيش الاسرائيلي
بيقول انه في شمال
غزه مجموعه من حماس تركت ثلاثه من الرهائن
او المحتجزين لاسباب لا يعلموها واصبح
الثلاثه محتجزين دول في مواجهه الجيش
الاسرائيلي فشعر بالامان وحبوا ان هم
يشعروا بالامان اكثر ان هم يسلموا نفسم
للجانب
الاسرائيلي لكن فوجئوا انه كتيبه كامله
بتطلق عليهم النار رغم ان هم خلعوا
ملابسهم يعني الجزء الاعلى عشان يقولوا ان
هم تماما غير مسلحين ورفعوا اشاره بيضاء
ان احنا مستسلمين ولكن اطلق الجيش
الاسرائيلي على اثنين منهم ا النار
فقتلوهم واللي تمكن من الحرب واختبا في
مبنى ا يعني استدعوه او طلبوه ولما خرق
قتلوه من مسافه تكاد تكون صفر انا بروي
القصه كده مظبوط اه بس في تفاصيل ممكن
ايضا يكون لها اهميه ان احنا نذكرها اولا
المجموعه الثلاثه دول محتجزين اسرى ا في
جميع الاحوال هم عملوا اللي عليهم الزياده
هو اول حاجه كتب على الحيطان في ثلاثه
مخطوفين
بالعبري انقذونا ادي اشارات ان في هنا حد
بيستغل علشان الناس تتنبه اللي هي القوات
الاسرائيليه في نفس الوقت الساعه كانت 10
صباحا واضح النهار يعني واضح النهار
فمافيش حجه ان انا مش شايفك ومش واخد بالي
انت جاي في وقت مريب انت بتتقدم لي زحف
ماشي على رجله مافيش سلاح ونصف العلوي
عاري زي ما حضرتك اشارت وجابه فعلا خرقه
بيضا وقطعه من ماسوره اصرفوا بقى في عالم
ابيض ماشيين بيه فالمهم اللي انا عايز
اشير اليه ان في قناص قاعد في مكان عالي
داخل مبنى من جيش الاحتلال رب عليهم وقال
حبلين حبلين مخربين مخربين ناس ابتدت تضرب
على الثلاثه اللافت للنظر ان الكتيبه
بتضرب و مكان عالي وناس مكشوفين في وضح
النهار اصابوا اثنين وفي واحد لم يصب باذى
ده راجع المبنى تاني فده الجوزيه بتاعه
الكتيبه دي تقصد ان هم ليس لديه المهاره
يعني اه المهاره ان انت دي بط على رجاء
يعني واحد مش راكب حاجه مش متحصن بحاجه
مكشوف ورافع ايده وماعرفتش تجيبه انت و
وزمايلك عرف يعني اه ما فيش مالكش حجه ان
انت ماجبوش فهو دخل المبنى بالفعل ففي
قائد وهو خارج قال اضربوا النار يعني ما
فيش غلطه في النص ان في عمل فردي في قائد
تحت المقدم تحت قائد الكتيبه ادى الامر
للجنود ونفذه اعدموه ميدانيا ده الشخص
الثالث اللي هو اختبا بالمبنى ده الثالث
اللي اختبا بالمبنى فاولا في عدم جهزيه
يعني سيبك من الاخلاق سيبك من القانون
الدولي انا بتكلم على الجوزيه
ان هو جيش غير قادر على ان هو يصطاد ثلاثه
مكشوفين ورافعين ايديهم الحاجه الثانيه ان
ده مش حادث قتل خطا يعني قتلنا ثلاثه من
الاسين بالخطا الخطا ان انا اكون سايق
عربيتي اخبط واحد اموته فده قتل خطا او ان
انا تطلع من طبنجته حاجه بسبيل الخطا ف
قتل خطا انما ده اعدام ميداني واحد مستسلم
رافع ايده مع الالم فده اللي احنا بنشير
اليه مبدئيه طب قبل ما اسالك عن احنا
عندنا كده مستويين للمناقشه ايوه مستوى
ليه الاسرائيليين قتلوا جنودهم ده واحد
اثنين لماذا بالغوا في الاعلان عن قتل
الجنود ابدا بالسؤال الاولاني ايه هي
دوافع الكتيبه الاسرائيليه في انها تقتل
ثلاثه هل اعتقدت انهم مثلا مقاومين
فلسطينيين هل ما السبب يعني يعني في واحد
سيناريوهات افتراضيه نظري ممكن ده يكون
تخبط ممكن يكون تخلف ممكن يكون عمدا ان
انا بصفي ناس حتى لو في احتمال 1 في ان هم
يكونوا من
الاسر على سبيل الانتقام من الفلسطينيين
اي حد بيتحرك بيسته في قطاع غزه بالكامل
في ناس بتقول من الجانب الاسرائيلي مدونين
ان انتم عايزين تخلصوا من الاسر ان ده
توجه عند الجيش الاسرائيلي بان دول مجموعه
لم تصمد يوم 7عه واستسلمت يعني كان ممكن
تقاوم وتموت او انها تنتصر ولا انتصرت ولا
ماتت فهي فضلت الاست استسلام فبالتالي وفي
بعد تاني ان ثمن الصفقه هيقل احنا دلوقتي
داخلين في صفقه فلما العدد يقل ثمن الصفقه
في المقابل هيبقى ق كانيه الكل مقابل الكل
دي هيبقى فيها معادله تانيه اذا انت بتقول
اولا دوافع الكتيبه او العسكريين في
الميدان لقتل ثلاثه من جنودهم واحده من
ثلاثه صحيح اما انها حاله ارتباك وذعر
وبالتالي انا بضرب على كل
الناس اي حد تحرك
واحد اثنين
انه وده واضح ان ده يعني ناتج عن الضغط
العنيف للمقوم اللي مخهم في حاله عدم ا
صباع الزنات سهل يضغط ده مش قواعد اشتباك
ابدا ده عوض نفسي اه فواحد ارتباك وخوف
بيخليهم دايما مستعدين لاطلاق النار على
كل هدف يتحرك اثنين انه عدم تعاطف مع
الاسرى معنى ذلك ان هم عرفوهم ولكنهم
ليسوا متعاطفين معهم لان هؤلاء وضعوهم في
مازق بجبنهم وعدم قدرتهم على مقاومه
المهاجمين يوم سبعه واسرهم ضف لذلك ان
اسرهم بتضغط واحنا متعطلين بسبب هذه
النداءات ا لاثه بقى انت بتقول انه توجه
عام لو نقدر نقتل اكبر عدد من الاسرى ده
يجعل من التفاوض مع حماس ليس اولويه ولو
تم التفاوض يتم التفاوض على عدد اقل من
الاسرى الاسرائيليين وبالتالي الثمن الذي
سوف تكون اسرائيل مضطره لدفعه اقل صحيح ده
كلام بيقوله مدونين و
متداول متداول لكن اذا تركنا يعني
انا اذا تركنا ليه هم عملوا كده احنا اصلا
عندنا سؤال ثاني هم ليه حماس ثبتهم اصلا
اذا كانوا هم في حوزه حماس ولكن ده موضوع
ممكن اسالك عنه في وقت اللاحق لما تتضح
الصوره السؤال الاهم بالنسبه لي
الاسرائيليين قتلوا جنودهم لاي سبب في
الغالب نقول نعطيهم حسن الظن ونقول
ارتباك ليه الجيش الاسرائيلي ممثل ثلا في
المتحدث باسمه يبالغ جدا في كشف الخطا
اللي ارتكبه الجيش الاسرائيلي كان يمكن
يقول ان احنا قتلنا بالخطا ثلاثه جنود ليه
يصر على ان هؤلاء الجنود كانوا في وضح
النهار وكانوا مستسلمين وا يعني وكانوا من
مسافه قريبه يعني ماذا يستفيد المتحدث
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي في الايغال
والمبالغه في ادانه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعني في حاجه نظريه برض ان
الجانب المقاوم كان يرصد هذه العمليه وهي
عباره عن جس نبض او توقع مبكر منه كيفيه
تعامل القوات الاسرائيليه مع اي شيء يتحرك
وبالتالي سيتعامل مع هؤلاء باي صوره فسجل
صور الواقع وثقه ده سيناريو السيناريو
الاخر اللي انا برجح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
انا ما فهمتش السيناريو الاولاني ان حماس
صورت الواقعه و يها فلا يستطيع ان ينفيها
اه ما يقدرش خلاص دي كده واضحه اه ده
سيناريو يعني
احتمال الحاجه الثانيه وانا اللي برجعها
هي دي ان الجيش الاسرائيلي اصبح مخترق في
الصراع بين المستوى السياسي والمستوى
العسكري وان الذراع بتاع نتنياهو داخل
الجيش الاسرائيلي احد وجوهه هو المتحدث
العسكري دانيال هنج ف الفكره الاساسيه ان
هو بالشكل اللي اعلنه ده يحاكم هو متحدث
العسكري بهذا الشكل يبث روح سلبيه لدى
الجنود اثناء الحرب وده وفق القانون
الاسرائيلي يعاقب عليه بالسجن ثلاث سنوات
اربع سنوات فده هو عرض نفسه للحكايه دي
لانقاذ نتنياهو هو نتنياهو دلوقتي بيقول
ايه بيقول القماشه كده هو المستوى بتاع
الجيش كده جهوزيته كده ف فانا قلت وعود
كبيره هغير الشرق الاوسط هغير الخريطه
هقضي على حماس انما ما فيش قماشه اصلا
فالمستوى بتاع الجزيه مستوى الكفاءه هو
كده فيلا اوريكم بقى المستوى الحقيقي بتاع
الجيش الاسرائيلي عشان ينقذ نفسه هو طبعا
بيذبح البقره المقدسه الوحيده في اسرائيل
اسرائيل اسرائيل قايمه على جداره القوه
ليس جداره تاريخ جداره وجود على ارض
الواقع والقانون هي قايمه ان ليها جيش قوي
وان في دوله عظمى بتحمي هذا الجيش القوي
وبتخليه دايما متفوق وقادر على الردع فهو
دلوقتي بيحرق هذه الورقه بيحرق هذا
التاريخ في سبيل ان هو ينقذ نفسه وانضم
ليه ابنه ابنه يعني ابتدى يقول يوجه سهام
النقد للجميع ان الجميع غلطان بما فييه
الجيش بما فيه يقاف جلنت وزير الدفاع بما
فيه رئيس الاركان في سبيل ان نتنياهو مش
غلطان هو الامكانيات كده استاذنك ان انا
اتاكد من فهم اللي اللي انت قصدته انت
بتقول تفسير تاني طبعا التفسير الاولاني
خلاص انت قلته انه الجيش اعلن وبالغ في
الاعلان عن خطئه لان المقاومه ربما قد
صورت الواقعه
وبالتالي خلاص لا يستطيع الانكار هذا واحد
انت بتقول ان في تفسير ثاني ان هناك
انقسام عنيف ما بين العسكريين والسياسيين
ده كلنا رصدناه يعني
وانه القياده السياسيه على الاقل تريد ان
تتبرا من الاخطاء المتتاليه التي ارتكبت
منذ يوم سبعه القياده السياسيه متمثله في
نتنياهو عاوز يقول ان الاخطاء وعدم قدرته
على تحقيق النصر حتى الان ولا اي من
الاهداف المعلنه وعلى راسها استعاده
الاسرى والمخطوفين الكلام ده لم يتحقق ليس
بسبب خطئ ولكن بسبب عدم كفاءه الجيش وواحد
من ا البراهين على عدم كفاءه الجيش هو انه
بيقتل جنوده في وضح النهار على مسافه
قليله وهم مستسلمون جميل مظبوط كده اللي
ياكد الخط ده المروحيات اللي احنا اتكلمنا
قبل كده انها اتت من شمال اسرائيل الى
قطاع غزه وقتلت عشوائي الاسرائيليين كان
اغلب القتلى يوم 7 اكتوبر بال مروحيات دي
احنا اشرنا ليها قبل كده الجديد يا سيد
بيه ان قالوا كمان في دبابات ضربت يوم 7ب
اكتوبر كان في دبابتين والغريب ان طلعوا
فيديو للدبابه وهي بتضرب بيت في ئن
اسرائيليين في محتجزين اسرائيل
الاسرائيليين في كبوت باري الملاصق لغزه
وبتضرب ده قصف ثقيل اسلحه ثقيله بالضروره
هتقتل الاسرائيليين مع الفلسطينيين
والغريب ان هم برض اذاعوا ان في واحده
قالت اه انا اصبت بشا ازيه ولا قعدت اسرخ
انتوا بتعملوا ايه اصيبت الشاهده دي كانت
محتجزه جوه البيت لقت ان الدبابات بتضرب
عليهم ففي ناس اصيبت وناس ماتت بكل تاكيد
من الدبابات انا ما يهمنيش ان هم ماتوا ما
ماتوش ليه عملوا كده انا اللي يهمني
الاعلان مين اللي اعلن ان بعد المروحيات
ما دربت اسرائيليين مروحيات الجيش
الاسرائيلي دلوقتي بيعلنوا ان في دبابات
الجيش الاسرائيلي يوم سبعه ضربت المحتجزين
ده داخل بيوتهم في الكبوس اللي هو ملاصق
لغزه عايز اشير برض ان يوم 7:00 تم
الاعلان برضو عن ان تم اتلاف الملفات
الخاصه باردات كاميرات المراقبه واصبع
الاتهام موجه الى قاده الجيش
لانهم اخفقوا وعايزين يعني يتجاوزوا موضوع
التحقيق ضدهم في
القصيه استاذنك اوضح واصحح لي ايوه دكتور
احمد بيشير الى انه استمرارا لخط ادانه
الجيش الاسرائيلي اللي هو بيعتقد انها
عمليه ممنهجه من جانب السياسيين وعلى
راسهم نتنياهو حتى
يحمل الكل التقصير للجيش وينجو بنفسه من
التقصير مش بس الامعان في الاعلان عن
تقصير واضح وهو قتل الجيش لثلاثه من جنوده
في وضح النهار يوم 15 ديسمبر ولكن ده اكثر
من مره تم الاعلان عن تقصير مخجل للجيش هو
اشار للواقعه اللي احنا تحدثنا عنها من
عده حلقات وسوف اضع لكم رابتها انه تم
الاعلان عن تحقيقات داخليه في صلاح
الطيران خلاصتها كده انه سلاح الطيران جاء
متاخرا وجاءت كتيبه او جاء يعني طيارين من
مسافه بعيده من قاعده بعيده بينما كان
هناك طيارين يمكن ان ياتوا من مسافه اقرب
وينقضوا الموقف بشكل اسرع حين جاؤوا
تصرفوا بشكل غير مهني ادى الى انه قتلوا
اليهود اه قتلوا اليهود قالوا ان حماس قدت
تعليمات لعناصرها تجري بلا تجري اه لكن
الخلاصه لان احنا قلنا التفاصيل انه هؤلاء
الطيارين قتلوا من اليهود اكثر مما قتلوا
من المقاومين وبيضيف ثاني انه
اعلن وهنن شر الرابط يعني انه في نفس
اليوم كانت في دبابتين وعدد كبير من
الجنود زي ما انا فهمت الدكتور احمد
وعاوزين يتعاملوا مع بيت
في فلسطينيين معاهم محتجزين يهود مظبوط
الجنود دول بقى مشكلتهم اكبر ان هم قاعدين
بره المكان بالكامل ساعات سايبين القتال
جوه الاشتباك جوه ولم يتدخلوا لساعات بدون
سبب مفهوم فده برض اصبع اتهام للجيش انتوا
ما دخلتو ليه انقذت الناس ده في يوم سبعه
برض برض يوم سبعه ففي احد البيوت في رهائن
مظبوط يا دكتور او في محتجزين ومعاهم عدد
من رجال المقاومه
الفلسطينيه فالطبيعي في الحاله دي ان
بتتدخل قوات خاصه عشان على الاقل
يحيدوا الفلسطينيين ينقذوا رهائن استخدموا
دبابات يعني قذائف ثقيله يعني عارف انه
هيقتل ده مع ده وكان في جنود عدد كبير من
الجنود يمكن ان يتدخل لكن بيقول ان هؤلاء
لم يتدخلوا وبيضيف مثال ثالث انه تم الاع
تم اتلا في الكاميرات التي وثقت لحظات
الهجوم طبعا دايما في كل واحده من الحوادث
الثلاث عندنا مستويين ليه ده حصل قد يكون
الجيش قسر قد يكون اتلف قد يكون لكن مش دي
مشكلتنا الاعلان هو المشكله ان الاعلان
بيدين الجيش بشكل واضح صحيح فانا لو مشيت
مع الخط ده هبطه على طول بتفتيش وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي وداخل ديوان رئيس
الوزراء تفتيشه بحثا عن اجهزه تسجيل فلما
اللي تفتش رئيس الاركان ولا وزير الدفاع
الاثنين الاثنين بس اللي كان عنيف جدا
وزير الدفاع قال انا اجيب لكم كتيبه انت
اجيب لك كتيبه انت حارسه وعايزه تفتشي ل
وزير الدفاع هو مش ناقص هو يعني يعني من
يوم سبعه وهو يعني من جميع الجهات ولسه
عنده التوتر ان لسه لبنان ممكن تتفتح ولا
مش هتتفتح
وممكن الجبهات اخرى تتفتح فهو الناقصه
كمان ان حارسه تيجي تقول له انت معاك جهاز
تسجيل ولا لا ف حصل مع رئيس الاركان
نفس الامر وكان برض ليه رد زجر كده
واشتباك يعني مع الحراسه مع الحراسه فهو
الفكره ان في تشكك من الجانبين انت جاي
تسجل لي لا انا جاي اهينك والاعلان مين
اللي بيعلن ما انا عرفت منين ما هو في حد
اعلن عشان يحرج الثاني ان هو انت ما لا
يليق برئيس الاركان اللي هو راس الهرم في
جيش الاحتلال ان يتم عملته كده ان ما فيش
ده
ضد اللي توارثته اسرائيل طوال الفترات
اللي فاتت من ان ده الجندي رقم واحد ان ده
القائد الفعلي تاني وزير سياسي المشكله
بقى في اسرائيل ان وزير الدفاع مش سياسي
وزير الدفاع ا جنرال يف جالانت وانا شرحت
لحضرتك قبل كده ان الزحمه دي اللي حصلت ان
اثنين واساء اركان موجودين ايزن كوت جه وك
رئيس اركان سبك بقى وزير في حكومه الحرب
جانتس وزير دفاع سابق بقى وزير في حكومه
الحرب وفي اثنين مايوش انا قلت ح هم في
مناصبهم عادي رئيس الاركان ووزير الدفاع
فواحد بيقول انا ما فشلت ادوني فرصه واحد
بيقوللك انا مش جاي مستشار الاجواء دي
تعمل على طول الارتباك والتخبط انما اللي
عاييز اوصل له يوم الثلاث 19 ديسمبر لا
استاذنك قبل ما توصل ليوم 29 ديسمبر تقصد
لا لسه 29 جايه 19 اه انت عندك ايام كتير
عاوز توصل لها ان انت هنا النقطه اللي انت
دي نقطه مهمه انت بتقول ان انت تفسيرك
لمحاوله ادانه الجيش لنفسه هو الصراع ما
بين السياسيين
والعسكريين وانه احد تجليات هذا الصراع
انه الجيش مخترق من جانب نتنياهو بعسكري
يؤيدن نتنياهو وهؤلاء عسكريين يدينون
الجيش ارضاء لنتنياهو ان الجيش ده ضعيف
مقصر وبالتالي نتنياهو لا يجب ان يتحمل كل
هذه الاخطاء ده مش ده اللي انت قصدك عليه
يا دكتور اه بس هي ما بتحسب كده بتبقى
مصالح شخصيه ما انا جايس هوده سؤالي
بالضبط دلوقتي انتوا في المتحدث ده ضابط
رتبه عميد في الجيش الاسرائيلي صحيح
العميد ده هو اللي اتكلم وقال هو اللي
بالغ جدا في فتح يعني ضعف الجيش
الاسرائيلي ي 15 كان ممكن يغد البصر يعني
ما يقولش التفاصيل لاثه مات واشتباك حتى
لو صورت حماس يشكك في الفيديو اي حاجه
يعني اي حاجه يعني فانت هنا ماذا يستفيد
احنا بما ان ده هيضر الجيش وهذا ضابط في
الجيش فانت كده بتوحي ان هذا المتحدث هو
من معسكر نتنياهو الذي يخترق الجيش اه
طبعا انا بقول ليه كده هو هنجاري دوت ا
عميد و طبعا هو اللي بيقود ال
الدعايه لاسرائيل وجيش الاحتلال في الحرب
ديت انما هو ازاي انت بتتعامل معايا انا
اعرف السياسيين الاسرائيليين بيفكروا ازاي
فهو بيقول له انت كده كده هتقعد مين اللي
بيقول لمين بقى نتنياهو او من يمثله بيتفو
ازاي مع الناس دي بيقول له دلوقتي انت كده
كده هتتقابل
انت كده العداد بتاعك يعني مش هترق اكتر
من كده فبعد كده تبقى معانا في مقدمه
القائمه بتاعه الليكود
للكنيست فهتبقى واخد مقعد مضمون وممكن
اديك نائب وزير فالتاني بيقول له على طول
يقول له لا انا عايز ابقى وزير نقل انا
عايز ابقى وزير
اتصالات ليه بيقول كده لان المتحدث اللي
قبله برتبه عميد برض بقى وزير متحدث باسم
جيش الاحتلال في 2005 ميري ريجف دي دي
ضابطه مالهاش خبره سياسيه انهت حرب لبنان
انهت التغطيه الاعلاميه اللي هي متحدثه
200 اه و 2005 غزه كانت هي دي فترتها
استلمت على طول عضو كنيست نائب وزير وزير
اشتغلت ايه وزير ثقافه ماشي وزير هي اللي
لبست الفستان اللي مكتوب عليه القدس وسوره
الاقصى وكده فهو ده الطريقه ازاي انا
بتفاوض مع حد بحيث ان
هو يديني اللي انا عايزه حتى لو لو
هيقالو حتى لو يوبخ هو بس انت طبعا يعني
لايضاح انت بتقول ان ده سيناريو وارد انت
بت ده العادي ده العادي في ازاي انا بقنع
واحد ان هو ينط من المعسكر ده يجي المعسكر
بتاعي لا مفهوم بس ده استنتاجك يعني هذا
تحليل ا بالبط طب ما هو لو كان على هذا
التحليل معنى كده ان ممكن هذا المتحدث
مثلا يقال لانه هو بيضر بالجيش اللي
بينتمي اليه هو مش من المتبعه ان حد يقال
اثناء الحرب لكن في نفس الوقت اذا وقيل
قدم نفسه ان هو بتاع المصداقيه وان هو
ماكدبش وعشان بيقدم الحقيقه وان هو تعذل
لضغوط كنت عاوز تقول حاجه على يوم 19
ديسمبر اللي هو احنا بنسجل الحلقه يوم 20
فانت تشير الى امس الثلاثاء 19 ديسمبر
ماذا جرى في هذا
اليوم في يوم 19 ده يوم فاصل يمكن في
تاريخ اسرائيل كلها لان الجانب
السياسي تكتل ضد الجانب العس عسكري بمعنى
ان بنج فير في اني مكان يعني في الكنيست
جو جوه المجلس الوزراء الامني المصغر اه
كان في
اشتباك المصغر ولا
الواسع المصغر المصغر في مجلس حرب في مجلس
الحرب ده فوق خالص بنفير مش فيه اه انما
مجلس الوزراء الامن المصغر فيه بنفير ف هو
وزير وزير الامن القومي اه
فده اشتبك للمره الثانيه او الثالثه مع
رئيس الاركان على خلفيه مسجد تم تجنيسه في
الضفه الغربيه وتم ف تلاوه صلاه في
الميكروفونات اسمها شمع اسرائيل دي صلاه
وراثيه استفزت طبعا المشاعر والامور يعني
اشعلت فالمهم تم تجميد عمل تعليق عمل
الجنود دول عقوبه مخففه جدا يا ما فيش حنك
اذكر الناس انه في الايام الماضيه من
حوالي اسبوع 10 ايام جنود اسرائيلين في
الضفه الغربيه صح في اي مدينه في جنين ج
دخلوا مسجد ا لاي سبب فاذا كان عندهم اي
دوافع امنيه حققوها لكن هم ما اكتفو بكده
ده هم اقاموا صلوات توراتيه المايكات في
المايكات في اهانه لمشاعر المسلمين هناك
وتصرف غير مبرر قائد الاركان وقع عليهم
عقوبه الدكتور احمد بيقول مخففه لكن وقع
عليهم عقوبه لكن هذه العقوبه رغم ان هي
مخففه لتصرفه الغير مبرر اغضبت بن غفير
اللي هو وزير الامن الداخلي المتطرف
المستوطن المتطرف
بدايه التفاعل من بن جبر اذاء الهجوم على
المسجد وتدنيسه واستخدام المايكات ثم
العقوبه المخففه من رئيس الاركان ان هو
راح وتعاطف معاهم وسانده الجنود
وكرمهم واستفزاز اكثر واكثر مكت انتفاش ب
كده في مجلس الوزراء الامني المصغر ابتدا
يقول لازم يرجعوا وقف يرجعوا الخدمه اه
وقف العقوبه عقوبه التعليق
ديت لا اما هيحصل ما لا يحمد عقبيه ئيس
الاركان قالوا لا انت ما تهددنيش انا
ماقبلش فدخل يوف جالانت اللي هو وزير
الدفاع يساند رئيس الاركان وقال يعني شويه
سياسيين عديم المسؤوليه وبيتكلموا معان
بال ريقه دي فال عديم المسؤوليه هم كمان
تعاطفوا مع بن جبر وت عارف اللي على راس
المطح ويقوللك اه ده انا ده يقصدني انا
فراح دخلوا في المعركه فبقى في شق واضح
بين السياسيين وبين العسكريين في هذه
المعركه اللي بيعتبر البعض ان ده اشاره
الى انقلاب عسكري قادم في اسرائيل ده ايه
الكلام الخطير ده يا دكتور ده هو بالكلام
اللي ما تذاكرش انما الجانب الاسرائيلي
قالوا من خلال تحليل ان دول مش
ناويين يستمر الوضع على هذا العسكريين دول
الاثنين دول هيقضوا تحرك للاطاحه بنتنياهو
طب انا استاذنك قبل ما اناقشك في هذا
الكلام الخطير انا بس عندي الف علامه
استفهام على عقليه حد زي بن غفير ايوه انا
عارف ان هو متطرف وعارف انه هو كاره
للفلسطينيين وكاره للعرب وكاره للمسلمين
لكن باعتباره ان هو في الاخر بني ادم لديه
عقل ما الذي يدفع مسؤول لديه عقل ان يكرم
جنودا ارتكبوا انه يخشوا معبد هندوسي
ولا سيخي ولا بوزي ولا اسلامي ولا
مسيحي ويصر ان يقيم صلاته في هذا المسجد
هذه اساءه تؤدي الى اضطرابات لا مبرره لها
فهو ايه تفكيره يعني يعني عاوز يكرم
الجنود دول ليه هو اولا دلوقتي يقولون عن
اسرائيل دوله بنفير ان هو اللي استولى على
القرار وخطف قرار الحكومه وان الاقليه
اللي بتتبعه اللي هي المستوطنين ههم الذين
يقودون المسار الحالي الذي ادى الى
الاعدامات الميدانيه يعني الخسائر دي بسبب
الهوس اللي هو فيه اللي هو الرغبه في
التوسع والاهانه واستفزاز الاخر في حين ان
هو ما عندوش خبره عسكريه ما هو ده برض جزء
مؤثر في بناء الشخصيه ان هو كان خطر على
الجيش الاسرائيلي ف منع من اداء الخدمه
العسكريه هو فوضوي هو من انصار حركه كاخ
احد تلاميذ مائير كهانه فقالوا له لا ما
ينفعش تخش انت ليه لان هو سبق ليه ان هو
وصل الى الماركه بتاعه عربيه رئيس الوزراء
رابين وقال 94 و95 اه 95 نوفمبر قتل انما
كان اللي قتله كان في سباق بينه وبين
بنفير مين اللي يقتله الاول فهو بنفير كان
بيتفاهم انجازه يعني اكبر انجاز ليه ان
انا زي ما وصلت باركه السياره اقدر اوصل
لصاحب السياره طبعا الدكتور احمد بيشير
الى اسحاق ربين رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
الذي قتل في نوفمبر 95 وهو بيمثل في
اسرائيل رمز للسياسي ل اراض التفاوض بجديه
مع الفلسطينيين وبن غفير كان بيحاول بيتصب
مع ان هو نازي فبالتالي يستحق الخيانه
وانه قدر يحصل على رقم سيارته وقال كما
وصلت الى رقم سياره اسحاق اه المركه نفسها
الشعار بتاع الموديل اللوجو اللوجو اللي
هو بيبقى في بدايه العربيه ماشي الحال
يعني وصل ال مش رقم مش هخد اللوحه يعني لا
لا يعني عرف يعني قدر يوصل الى السياره
وكما وصلت للسياره استطيع ان اقتله لكن
يعني مش عارف يعني هي يعني علامات استفهام
غريبه لراجل مثل هذا يصل الى السلطه طيب
اوكي انت قلت بقى كلام
خطير ده تحليل خاص بيك ولا ابتدت
الصابع مختلفه او مخاوف مختلفه دخل
اسرائيل تشير الى الانقسام ما بين
السياسيين والعسكريين اللي احنا بنتكلم
عليه من اول حلقه ربما يؤدي الى انقلاب
عسكري لا لا لا مش تحليل انا ده تحليل
جانب من المحللين الاسرائيليين بيقولوا
نتنياهو هيعمل ايه مع الناس دي مين اللي
هيسب الاول مين اللي هياخد الخطوه الاولى
هو الكلام ان الشق والصدع بقى واضح اه وان
كل واحد دماغه الخطه بتاعته واضحه انما
مين اللي هيتغلب اني قبل ما الثاني يتعشى
بيه هي دي اللي ايه اللي فيها الجدل خاصه
طبعا وان الجيش الاسرائيلي في لقطه
المقاومه عناصر المقاومه مطلع توثيق لخيمه
والعناصر المقاومه بتطلع اه ده صحيح اولا
يعني الاستاذه ليلى علوي لما كانت رايحه
تسرق البنك في فيلم كانت عامله خطه افضل
من كده في
التامين يعني يعني دي حاجه يعني تنفع في
رمضان كده نعمل عنها 30 حلقه يعني اضحك مع
جر ساوي مثلا الخيمه دي كانها محطوطه مثلا
على شاطئ بلاج يعني ابسط الحاجات اللي
بتتعمل التامين ان اولا ما يبقاش في نقطه
ميته يعني انت تبقى في مكان كاشف المنطقه
من الاربع جهات الحاجه الثانيه ان انا
بجيب شيله مثلا لاها رمله اعمل تحصينات
احفر عشان انزل اقعد في حته مؤمنه حفره
انما مافيش مافيش اي حاجه خالص مافيش عنصر
بيراقب القادم انت بتشير الى الواقعه اللي
المقاومه هجمت فيها على جنود اسرائيليين
وقبل هذا الهجوم ان كان في حد خرج من بين
الخيم للجنود الاسرائيليين وصور المشهد او
استطلع ثم تم الهجوم تم الهجوم وهم قالوا
الحمد لله احنا اجهدنا الهجوم ده كانوا
عايزين يخطفوا واحد اه وبس الحمد لله
مات فده المستوى اللي هو بيتعاملوا بيه
فده عامل يعني بس انت عاوز تقول الوق قع
دي كلها ده انت ده بتدلل بيه على الفشل او
عدم الكفاءه لكن ده ما هو اصلا حتى لو
يعني الجانب الاسرائيلي اخفى المقاومه
طلعت ان هو ده الامكانيات الحاجه الثانيه
النفق لا ما قبل الامكانيات انت كده بتدلل
بالمثل ده على ايه احنا كنا بنتكلم انه في
صدع كبير ما بين السياسيين والعسكريين اي
فانت عاوز تقول ايه من قصه الخيمه والجنود
اه اقول ان فعلا هو السياسي لهم حق ان هم
يشتبكوا مع الجيش الاسرائيلي ويقولوا لهم
مش احنا انتم ادونا حاجه نتفاوض بيها اه
ان السياسيين على حق ان الجيش قليل
الكفاءه اه فانا لما اطلع حاجه ضد الجيش
ما هو المقاومه طلعتها خلاص اه يعني اللي
هو الفيديوهات اللي بتطلع دي واحد واقف
على نص ركبه وبيضرب مبنى فاضي ما هو
الجانب الاسي بيطلع فيديوهات ما فيهاش
حاجه ما فيهاش تباك يعني والحاجه الثانيه
اللي وصلنا لها هي الانفاق النفق الكبير
اللي هو قالوا ده 15 برده اه قالوا في
احنا عملنا انجاز رهيب احنا لقينا نفق
بالقرب من ايرز معبر ايرز في شمال غزه وده
انجاز كبير ان احنا وصل اللي هو يعتبر
اقرب حاجه لحدود الاسرائيليه اه بال فانا
شايف ان اولا لاطمه للمخابرات الاسرائيليه
ان ازاي كم الاتربه
والرمال النفق ده يعدي دبابه مستريح مش
عربيه جيب ا وطول 4 كيلو لغايه ما وصلوا
له يعني قالوا احنا مش هنقدر نكمل دلوقتي
نبقى نشوف بعدين مش عارفين هو بعد الرب
كيلو ممتد لقد ايه انما المشكله ان
المخابرات الاسرائيليه العملاء المخابرات
الاسرائيليه اجهزه المراقبه ما شافوش
الاتربه اللي طالعه من الانفاق الحاجه
اللي بعدها ان النفق ده واكتشافه
وتصويره شهاده وفاه لفكره ان انا ممكن اغر
الانفاق بس مش عايز انت عارف في حرب نفسيه
كده ان انا جبت مضخات انا بدخ اهو انا
هبتدي اهو لانهم عاملين ابواب زي الخزن
بتاع المقاومه عامله ابواب محصنه تصد
المياه اه في حاله الاغراق انه يقدروا ان
هم يتحصن وراها بالضبط زي ما بيصد المطر
انا طبعا اذكر حضراتكم انه يوم 15 اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي 15 ديسمبر الجاري ان هم
وجدوا اكبر نفخ اكتشفوه حتى الان وهذا
النفخ كان يعني يعني عند معبر ايرز اللي
هو اقرب حاجه للحدود القانونيه لاسرائيل
يعني في الشمال بقى لهم قد ايه بقى لهم
ثلاث شهور في الشمال حاجه في منتهى
الغرابه ده مش نفق صغير نفق كبير جدا
فدكتور احمد بيقول يعني يعني ازاي اكيد ده
تم حفره على وقت طويل جدا عمليه حفره
واخراج التراب منه والمخلفات و وتشهده
المفروض انه كان حاجه يصعب اخفائها لفتره
طويله مع وجود كاميرات مراقبه وموجود
الزنانه والمطاط والدرونز
الاستطلاعيه كل الكلام ده هم بيفكروا ان
عندهم عملاء عدد كبير جدا داخل الاراضي
الفلسطينيه خاصه انه دي اقرب حاجه للاراضي
الاسرائيليه ومع ذلك لم يتم اكتشافه فده
حاجه غريبه بالمناسبه انا كنت بقول لك قبل
ما نسجل ان انا كان عندي هنا الدكتور
اسامه النحاس وهو راجل عنده خبرات
استثنائيه يعني في عالم الانفاق وسجل
معايا حلقه اعتقد انها يعني
استحق المشاهده لانه اجاب على بعض هذه
الاسئله ومنها سيناريو الاغراق ف استاذنكم
ان تعودوا اليه ده ما حدث يوم 19 اللي
اراد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يفخر به لكن في
حقيقه الامر هو كان بيدل على عدم كفائته
يعني على فكره في ملحوظه في بعض الاصدقاء
بيقولوا لي ان الحلقه قلبت الى شؤون
معنويه وان انتم تدعموا المقاومه رغم ان
دي مش جريمه يعني بس والله لا يعني انا
بقعد مع الدكتور احمد اقوله من فضلك لو
كان في انجازات للجيش الاسرائيلي اللي
عاوزين نقول ما كان زعه هو بيجيب واحد
بيضرب حيطه فاضيه بيرمي قنبله في نفق
وبيقول اكيد في حد تحت وده حادف لان في ب
ملاحظات بيقولوا لي انت يا سيد متعودين ان
انت تقول كلام
محايد ما لنا وما علينا ههم بعد ثلاث شهور
فين الانجاز ما خدوش ليه على المقاومه في
الشمال اه يعني مش مش ان انا يعني بحاول
ان انا احذف مثلا اسرائيل عملت انجاز كبير
وانا هم مش ما عندهمش حاجه زعو يعني حتى
اللي اعوه زي اكتشاف النفق ق انتوا شفتوا
اكتشاف النفق ماذا يعني يعني فشل
استخباراتي
خطير ليهم يعني اه صحيح رجعوا تاني
للمفاوضات بعد ما قال لا وانا عايز ستات
دلوقتي خلاص مش لازم
ستات هل تاذن لي ان انا اعود للموضوع
الكبير اللي انت قلته كده بشكل عابر
يعني يعني هل الحديث عن احتمال تحول
الانقسام ما بين عسكريين
وسياسيين الى مواجهه قد تصل الى انه ما هو
اصل السياسي ممكن يعمل ايه هيقدم كل هؤلاء
الى المحاكمه والمحاكمه هتقول رايها فيما
يجري من قصر ومن لم يقصر انما فكره ان
العسكريين يتحركوا ضد نتنياهو اذا تحركوا
بشكل قانوني هذا ليس ليس انقلابا انه
يتحركوا انه يدعموا فكره اسقاط الحكومه
اعتقد هذا ممكن انما فكره تتحركوا بمعنى
انقلاب عسكري هل هذا وارد في اسرائيل في
لمفترق الطرق اللي فيه اسرائيل انا
ماتبعدش ليه لان يوف جالنت قبل كده قال
انا صلاحياتي ان انا احمي امن اسرائيل وان
الخط اللي ماشيه بيه الحكومه دي غلط الخط
بتاع بنفير والمجموعه دي فنتنياهو اقال
اهنا كان وزير الفاع لعده اسابيع واضطر
يرجعه تاني فده بعد البعد الثاني ان احنا
امام حاله من الاحتقان في الشارع
والانقسام في الشارع عادت اللي كان قبل 7
اكتوبر وقالوا لا احنا معا ننتصر وكده لا
رجع اني الحاله دي اللي هو انقسام في
معسكر ضد نتنياهو معسكر مع نتنياهو فاللي
ضد نتنياهو ده مهما قعد يهاتي في الشارع
ما حدش هيستجيب الا لو في مؤسسه قالت
والله الظروف دي غير عاديه الظروف دي
طارئه ظروف استثنائيه واحنا شبه سنه 48
لازم نتحرك هو في اي سابقه في اسرائيل
لمحاولات انقلاب لا لا يوجد لا انا
الحقيقه هبقى مندهش ان هم يفكروا في كده
خصوصا انه الحرب يبدو انها يعني خلاص
بتدعى اوزارها لانه صعب ان تطول الحرب
اكثر من ذلك واذا توقفت الحرب هو نتنياهو
ساقط ساقط حتى انا قريت من ايام قليله او
من ساعات قليله يعني انه يناشد القضاء انه
يجمد ملاحقته لحين الانتهاء من الحرب
فيعني ليسوا في حاجه الى الانقلاب عليه
ولا انت عندك تصور اخر انا عندي تصور ان
المعركه الاساسيه لم تبدا بعد المشكله ان
احنا هندخل في الصفقه دي مستقبل حماس ولا
هنخش في مواجهه مع حماس حتى النهايه ففي
ظل هذا التصور نتنياهو لا يستطيع ان
يتفاوض ولا يستطيع ان يقود معركه بمعنى
ايه مش فاهم في مستوى ان انا في انا في
حماس عارف طلعت اخر ضابط عندي من جيش
الاحتلال اسير وسلمته خلاص هبتدي تدك اللي
بجد اسرائيل تبتدي تضرب بجد طبعا ما خلاص
بقى العبق ده والحساسيه دي فهن خش بقى في
مرحله ثانيه من الاشتباك فهي مش هتوافق
وتطلع اخر ضابط ولا عسكري الا اما تاخد
ضمانات سياسيه بانها ستشارك في الحكم انها
تكون راضيه عن المرحله القادمه ان في حد
ادنى من التفاهمات او ان التفاوض فشل فيلا
نخش المعركه الكبيره انت النهارده فاجئتنا
بامور كثيره معالي الدكتور ولكن يعني
مساله تحتاج عاوزه يعني عاوزه جدال وعاوزه
فرصه اوسع للمناقشه يعني فاستاذنتها
العناوين الكبيره للاسبوع المقبل تكون
الصوره بقت اوضح واوضح جزيل الشكر تحياتي
لحضرتك سي شكرا جزيلا لحضرتكم